hey 42 here the Great Wall of China was
funded by a state lottery welcome to RIF
Sylvester Stallone was so broke before
his script for Rocky was accepted that
he sold his dog for 25 dollars a few
weeks later he bought it back for
$15,000 in 2012 146 girls in the United
States were named Khaleesi the first
person to smoke in Europe was sent to
prison for being possessed by the devil
India's Mars probe costs less than the
movie gravity fruits are the ovaries of
plants in 1859 a panic swept America
because young people were playing too
much chess the longest bout of hiccups
lasted for 67 years elephants
tickle each other Apple is worth more
than Sweden Poland and Nigeria a 21
Mussolini was homeless and living under
a bridge in Switzerland at the 1956
Olympics Russian rower [ __ ] laughs
even oov was so excited at winning gold
that he dropped his medal into the lake
and it was never found before having
their chests cut open and their heart
pulled out Aztec human sacrifice victims
were given a cup of hot chocolate
Prince Charles runs his Aston Martin on
biofuel made from wine all glossy
magazines are radioactive as Oh die
carbonyl mind is a chemical compound
that makes things softer and bouncier
it's used in flip-flops yoga mats and
McDonald's Big Mac buns thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2